oui syriaques et le jugement vient de
tomber à l'instant un an de prison ferme
et un an avec sursis c'est le jugement
qui a finalement été prononcé ce soir à
l'encontre de serre il dit sir plus
connus comme vous l'avez dit sous le nom
de sissi percussions et auquel il est
reproché d'avoir mercredi passé sept
téléphones dans la prison de ducos à la
barre l'artiste âgé de 60 ans qui depuis
des décennies oeuvrent bénévolement dans
l'insertion sociale des détenus s'est
dit miné par cette affaire je vis avec
800 euros par mois at il expliqué je me
suis laissé emporter
je suis vraiment désolé alors si ses
percussions il est avec nous et quelle
est votre réaction ce soir à cette
affaire qui est vraiment allé très vite
et bien oui je dis merci quand même et
merci à tous ces jeunes en quelques mots
soutenu vous cette affaire mais je dis
aussi à m'excuser en toute sincérité de
vos la population martiniquaise et bien
au delà du département
je suis vraiment désolé vous avez
expliqué à la barre que vous aviez des
difficultés financières qu'on ne
connaissait pas forcément je veux
laisser mon avocat parler parce que
c'est lui de le gall et le monde qui
nous entoure
m et mme mayette qui justement a plaidé
qui a rappelé à que pour les artistes en
martinique la difficulté financière et
poursuivez parfois jusqu'à la tombe et
vous avez même dit certains meurent
pauvre comme job est ce que c'est ça qui
s'est passé c'est une vraie réalité chez
nous à la martinique
nos artistes nos musiciens aux
professionnels de la musique pour sauver
leur crédit cash leur misère sisi
percussions
c'est l'exemple malheureusement il est
tombé il a chuté il a commis une
grossière erreur
nous avons cet après-midi dû affronter
la juridiction
la décision qui a été rendue est une
décision qui ne me convient pas tout à
fait mais qui est un point positif c'est
que il n'y a pas de mandat de dépôt de
données donc ça veut dire qu'ils ne
rentrent pas au centre pénitentiaire de
ducos
nous avons dix jours pour l'apprécier
nous prendrons le temps je vais surtout
attendre qu'il se soit reposée et dans
un contexte à ce moment là j'ai presque
envie de dire plus réfléchie
nous verrons à ce moment-là ce qu'il
convient de faire ce que vous faites
appel ou pas vous savez ça déjà non ce
soit il serait prétentieux d'affirmer
déjà que nous allons en appel
je veux d'abord qu'il se ressource qu'il
retrouve sa famille qu'il retrouve sa
femme
et puis dans la semaine nous ferons le
point et nous verrons à ce moment là si
nous devons ou pas fait rappeler
simplement ce que je retiens c'est que
il fait peu de choses pour que nos
hommes une femme puisse glisser tomber
et commettre l'irréparable
si vous l'avez rappelez vous il avait un
il avait un casier judiciaire vierge
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce soir
alors une question quand même sur cette
cette infraction sept téléphones
portables qui ont été passés c'est
toujours illégal en france d'avoir un
téléphone portable à l'intérieur d'une
prison
absolument c'est toujours illégal
d'avoir un téléphone portable à
l'intérieur d'une prison
la garde des sceaux madame belloubet de
ce point de vue a essayé d'améliorer la
situation et a prévu que désormais dans
chacune des cellules
il y aura un téléphone fixe permettant
aux détenus d'appli c'est une excellente
chose
d'autant que vous savez il ya toujours
un système parallèle qui fonctionne et
je peux dire ici et affirmé que ses
téléphones portables qui circulent non
seulement la justice on a connaissance
mais quelquefois même c'est un moyen
commode pour obtenir des aveux ou un
certain nombre de deux de précision
qu'on n'aurait pas obtenu par un autre
monde merci beaucoup m philippe
edmond-mariette alors il faut il faut
savoir aussi que il y avait un deuxième
prévenu
ici c'est le détenu qui avait commandité
la transaction cette transaction des
portables il effectue actuellement une
peine de prison pour meurtre et lui il
écope de deux ans de prison ferme avec
mandat de dépôt c'est à dire qu'il est
parti ce soir à ducos